last week marked the 45th anniversary of
the original star wars movie there are
now a total of nine movies in the series
though and if you are looking to
celebrate the force look no further than
the movie prop experience jc is live at
the neanopolis with more hey jc his
favorite place he's always having fun
hey jillian and rocky this is amazing
down here you know what star wars opened
up the first week it only made half a
million dollars week two it made two
million dollars all because of word of
mouth and this is tiana with the movie
prop experience and they have incredible
actual props from the movie to show you
guys today let's start down here at the
end thanks for having us start off with
these trinkets
okay these trinkets are actually from
the movie the last jedi
and in the movie there is the canto bite
casino so you'll see these are some of
the dice one of the playing cards and
here you go now you can't use these in
vegas but
these are pretty cool are real cool yes
they are and tiana said i can touch
things so i do have yes if you come down
you can't touch it you gave me
permission to touch this i gave you this
uh this gun here in the back what do we
have here that is raise blaster from the
force awakens oh this is actually used
in the movie yes look at that you guys
isn't that incredible now the one back
here i noticed this the colors this has
to be a stormtroopers pistol yes it is
or blaster yes and that's once again
that is also from the force awakens okay
and yeah the i really love that movie
okay but actually rogue one was the best
of all of those now you guys sparked a
controversy by saying rogue one is the
best yes
i know this guy han solo and what do we
have here those are his his data
cylinders and you see he wears them in
his jacket
the stuff you have here is incredible
thank you how do you get your hands on
stuff like this this year the blaster
rifle from star wars episode one the
phantom menace okay and this is a heavy
blaster rifle this is actually a hero
okay um you have heroes and then you
have stunts
the heroes are kind of
you see them used closer up right stunts
are mainly rubber but as you can see
this is the real deal this is the yeah
this it's got metal okay okay and this
we purchased in auction
he there's a lot of ways to buy things
we've got a we've got a website of
course that you can pick up a lot of
great things uh this another one this is
a first order this is a stormtrooper
blaster rifle and look
star wars fans right now are geeking out
over this thing and this thing lights up
it does
it has multiple lights
and i think that this was in the movies
that the franchise that everyone loves
and back here whose hand am i looking at
who knows okay i wasn't there all right
this is a tie fighter this is his glove
and his gauntlet
and yes somebody actually has something
to do yeah sure somebody wore that
and which one is this from this is from
a force awakens and it's so funny
because when i think of star wars on the
original trilogy i think of the 70s and
80s ones eric behind the camera he grew
up on the new ones it's so funny it's
some people identify with different
movies uh we have lots more to come down
here at the movie prop experience
something you can't see but i can see is
that it's tough we're gonna show you
guys coming up here in a little bit
we're gonna send it back to you guys
sorry i got a studio
what a tease